[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table très heureuse de vous
retrouver autour d'un plat d'un dessert
et d'un invité pour parler cuisine
alimentation écologie mais aussi un peu
politique et cette semaine nous recevons
un invité exceptionnel Philippe guelluc
bonjour bonjour Brigit et merci d'être
avec nous et avec moi pour présenter
cette émission comme chaque semaine
Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre
bonjour Brigitte bonjour Philippe galuc
monsieur Montanet bonjour vous êtes le
prolifique auteur du chat un personnage
de BD qui vous rend célèbre en 1983 il
fait donc ses 40 ans cette année avec
cet album happy birthday monsieur
guelluc pourtant il n'a pas pris une
ride depuis sa naissance dans le journal
francophone le soir où le chat est en
noir et blanc c'est à partir d'une
collaboration avec la revue à suivre
qu'il passe à la couleur ce que l'on
sait moins c'est que vous l'avez créé en
fait en 1980 pour votre faire part de
mariage où il pose alors avec la femme
du chat cela a donné ensuite de
nombreuses bandes dessinées comme chacun
son chat l'avenir du chat le retour du
chat la vengeance du chat et vous chava
chat alors non ça c'est pas vrai le chat
s'expose aussi en 2003 au beauard de
Paris où le chat déambule comme en 2021
sur les Champs-Élysées avec des statues
monumental du félin le long de l'avenue
alors outre ce don pour le dessin vous
êtes un artiste complet acteur peintre
sculpteur chroniqueur présentateur
d'émission de télévision en Belgique
mais aussi en France on vous voit à côté
de Michel Drucker la France que vous
avez d'ailleurs choisi pour le menu du
jour Jean-Pierre oui exactement avec une
très franchouillarde blanquette de veau
et en dessert un classique de la
pâtisserie française un Paris Brest dans
le dessous des plats rendez-vous à aras
pour le champion du monde de la frite on
vous dévoile le gagnant dans cette
émission dans les pieds dans le plat
l'Italie plébisité pour sa cuisine les
français raffolent de pizza et de pasta
les Belges aussi reportage dans un
temple dédié au produits de la botte
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et
confidence alors Philippe guuc que dit
de vous cette blanquette de veau pas
facile à éclaircir et franchement la
facilité aurait été pour moi de donner
ma langue au chat bon je sais c'est
facile mais non j'ai cherché et j'ai
même le début d'une hypothèse et oui
pauvre Philippe guelluc vous êtes
écartelé entre deux pays voisins à
cheval sur deux cultures et donc sur
deux cuisines votre estomac lui penche
plutôt pour le waterzoy et la
mitraillette un totem de la malbouffe
belge ce sandwich à la viande et aux
frites bon appétit mais votre palais lui
vote plutôt pour le bon goût de la
France terre de gastronomie et berceau
de cette cuisine bourgeoise incarnée par
cette fameuse blanquette de veau qui
mijote sur le poil tandis qu'au coin du
feu on caresse le chat qui Ron ronne
encore facile image d'épinale de cette
recette séculaire que vous nous imposez
à nous Français au lieu de nous
surprendre avec des croquettes de
crevettes gris mais oui en philigran il
y a un message clair Philippe guelluc
vous tenez coûte que coûte à défendre
une réputation qui vous colle à la peau
depuis que vous êtes un visage familier
de notre télé celle du plus français des
Belges au prix de vexer Bruxelles est-ce
que je me trompe philipuc philipuc
complètement vous êtes dans dans
l'erreur parce que non vous savez à
Bruxelles ils sont on est tellement
habitué à tout ça donc pourquoi j'ai
choisi la blanquette de veau parce que
ma grand-mère l'a préparé comme personne
et que en Belgique j'aurais pu vous
apporter ou vous demander de faire des
croquettes ou crevettes mais vous savez
pas les faire ici j'aurais pu vous
demander des matches mais c'est pas la
saison alors nous on sait pas faire les
crevettes mais votre grand-mère BGE sait
faire la blanquette ah ben oui dans
l'autre sens nous beaucoup de blanquett
en Belgique j'adore mais bien sûr mais
j'adore la cuisine française parce que
sachez aussi aussi une chose c'est que
dans la partie sud du pays où l'on parle
français la France est évidemment notre
deuxième pays c'est notre culture on lit
la littérature française on lit parce
qu'on lit pas que des auteurs belges
hein chez nous on lit euh des des
journaux français on regarde la télé
française on va voir des même si tout ce
qui se fait en Belgique est formidable
et s'exporte depuis quelques années
merveilleusement euh nous nous
intéressons mais on prépare aussi on a
une grande communauté italienne en
Belgique et on adore la cuisine
italienne
finêes un peu écartel entre ces deux
cultures non je suis je suis je
m'enrichis de de d'accumuler les
cultures plutôt que de les diviser voilà
je suis pas écartelé ça veut dire qu'on
on est coupé en deux moi au contraire
j'ai j'ai l'impression d'avoir des
couches supplémentaire parce que je me
passionne pour les la culture des autres
et et et que j'aime découvrir des des
saveurs alors là je suis très impatient
parce peux all nous on va y aller alors
moi je peux pas savoir si elle est aussi
bonne que celle de votre grand grandmère
parce que j'ai jamais goûté mais alors
mais c'est une recette d'ENT temps qui
est faite par che Françoise qui est le
restaurant qui se trouve à côté de
l'Assemblée nationale aux Invalides et
qui nous a fourni cette blanquette de
veau alors on espère qu'elle va quand
même ressembler ou approcher celle de
votre grand-mère sans lesgaler j'imagine
h en plus ma grand-mère s'appelait
Françoise alors vous voyez ça tombe
bien soyez franc qu'est-ce qui faisait
le secret de cette blanquette de votre
grand-mère est-ce que vous la fantasmiez
ou est-ce que vraiment elle était très
bonne non elle était très bonne
y mettait aussi
ah pour une question non très très bonne
bravo françoisevo Fran le le il
yimettait aussi des petites boulettes de
des polpettes comme font les italiens
mais de de viande de veau ah donc
c'était une blanquette revisité un petit
peu pas revisité c'était c'était une
question de moyen le veau coûtait plus
cher la viande haché était meilleur
marché et donc on avait un peu il y
avait ce côté agréable cela dit si vous
aimez ça elle est délicieuse elle est
délicieuse j'adore et si si vous aimez
ça allez un jour au bistr d'Henry rue
princesse dans le 6e pour moi ça c'est
la alors lui il Meille blanquette de
Paris pour vousou du monde grand j'allis
vous demander justement si vous aviez
Prin rue Princesse le bistr d'Henri j'ai
connu le papa maintenant c'est les fils
qui ont continué la cuisine alors
qu'est-ce qui fait une différence parce
que globalement une blanquette c'est du
bon veau de la crème un œuf petit
champignons des petits oignons grelou
alors qu'est-ce qui fait que rue
princesse c'est la princesse des
blanquettes c'est pas moi qu'est-ce qui
fait que le chat et le chat c'est un
chat qui dit des conneries et pourtant
ça fait rire alors il y a il y a c'est
la touche du c'est peut-être son auteur
qui fait le chat oui voilà alors
Jean-Pierre trois astuces pour revisiter
la blanquette oui ben je rebondis sur la
grand-mère de Philippe puisquelle avait
déjà un peu rev en prie je vous en prie
n'insultez pas ma famille elle avait
déjà un peu revisiter cette blanquette
je trouve c'est une bonne idée avec des
des polpettes moi je trouve que ça
j'aurais pu le mettre dans ce que je
vais vous raconter alors le veau et la
viande reine de la blanquette mais
toutes les viandes blanches font
l'affaire he pourchanger donc on peut
faire une blanquette au poulet à la
dinde ou au lapin oser les épices aussi
de temps en temps pour réveiller cette
blanquette que certains trouvent un peu
pépère en mode asiatique avec du
gingembre et de la citronnelle dans la
crème ça marche très bien pourquoi pas
un peu de lait de coco aussi en version
des îles c'est très bon avec une touche
de vanille ça c'est très très bon une
petite vous grattez au dernier moment
une petite gousse de vanille dans la
crème et puis en version corsée avec au
dernier moment un tour de moulin mais
vous mettez pas du poivre mais vous
mettez du café et ça lui donne un petit
côté ça vous réveille cel si vous mettez
de la vanille dans la blanquette moi je
vous mets un bouillon cube dans la crème
brûlée que je vous servirai en dessert
et enfin vous pouvez opter aussi
sur j'ai vu enfin et en de mot on peut
opter aussi pour la blanquette au
poissons le saumon la lotte ou la sole
même des crevettes sont un PEC pour une
blanquette qui donc un peu Yodé
connaissez-vous le truc pour attendrir
la viande de veau qui doit être
évidemment un peu grasse un peu é tendre
fa taper dessus non comme Maité ah non
c'est en douceur vous vous la faites
vous vous la mettez dans un plat avec de
l'eau gazeuse pendant 2 3 He ah bon et
elle va je ne sais pas quel processus
chimie elle va s'attend long dedans ah
oui on la laisse 2 he 2 3 heur alors
est-ce que vous vous aimez cuisiner
est-ce que vous savez la faire cette
blanquette de veau ah oui ah oui ah oui
moi je cuisine beaucoup j'adore ça si
vous venez un jour à la maison je vous
préparerai mes petites coquilles Saint-
donc avec les recettes de votre
grand-mère pas que pas que non non ça il
l' jamais fait c'est des petites coquies
Saint-Jacques snacket que je mets sur un
lit de d'endive caramélisé et puis je n
je nape avec un un beurre blanc Z on dit
les chic avec un beurre blanc ça très
bon un peu d'amertu mais plutôt des
produits de la mer ou vous cuisinez de
tout tout vos plats signatures outre
cette récemment j'ai alors beaucoup la
cuisine italienne le le soouo de de veau
aussi dciisément il y a un truc avec le
veau et ou alors les toutes sortes de
pâtes je fais des lasagnes qui qui sont
qui sont parfaites VO et avec des
lasagnes fraîches et j'ai découvert
récemment le le CO et ppé je parler tout
à l'heure de la cuisine italienne si
vous voulez parce que je je l'ai fait et
voilà on était faitin pour l'autre ça
marche ah ouais la cuisine française
qu'est-ce que vous est-ce que vous aimez
les classiques bon là on voit bien que
c'est la Blanque de veau le buf
bourguignon pas du tout ah pour quelle
raison c'est le le vin qui est boire le
le vin ouvert que que dans l'assiette
que dans l'assiette ou et vous aimez
alors faire le marché c'est vous qui
allez choisir vos produits en fonction
de quoi de de la provenance de la
localité de la saison la saison de la
provenance tant que je peux euh de la
sympathie aussi que que j'ai pour les
les les pour les Mar c'est vrai ça joue
ça est sympa qui
nous ah moi une fromageère qui me
vendrait un fromage exquis en faisant la
gueule non je préfère manger un fromage
un peu moins bon chez une fromagère
sympa donc des fruits des légumes de
saison toujours faites attention à ça
pas de provenance lointaine pour
attention au bilan carbone ou ça ça vous
in non non je suis très préoccupé par ça
depuis des années et des années j'ai
découvert l'écologie à travers René
Dumont écrit formidable dans les années
70 et euh ça ne m'a jamais quitté donc
effectivement quand je vois que c'est
des haricots du Kenya euh j'évite oui
mais on fait vivre les cultivateurs du
Kenya aussi c'est mais c'est pas bon
pour la planète le dilemme parce que
sans les haricots achetés par les
Français ils peuvent crever de faim non
mais il faut encourager les cignans à
manger des haricots locaux ou et quand
vous partez au marché vous avez déjà une
idée précise de votre cuisine ou au
contraire vous aimez vous laisser guider
par les produits que vous allez
découvrir pour ensuite rebondir sur une
recette c'est plutôt ça évidemment c'est
c'est je je vois tiens le l'œil de de ce
poisson a l'air VI vif donc nous nous
allons nous allons le ramener à la
maison et puis j'ai fait mien une des
recommandations de Bocuse dans sa
cuisine du marché justement qui était le
livre bocus le PAP de la cuisine
française voà qui qui m'a ouvert les
yeux sur les merveilles de la
gastronomie et la façon de la
réaliser c'est qu'il conseillait de
faire ses courses après avoir mangé
parce que si on y va en ayant faim
soi-même on achète 10 fois trop ça c'est
sûr et c'est malin oui alors le chat on
on le on le connaît on le connaît bien
le chat puisque ça fait 40 ans
aujourd'hui qu'il qu'il accompagne nos
vies ouais il fait ses bougies alors le
chat il est un peu empâé quand même faut
dire alors pourquoi l'avoir dessiné
comme ça en plus là il sort du gâteau on
a l'impression qu'il a mangé l'intérieur
du gâteau non non mais c'est un gourmand
mais c'est un gourmé qui préfère plutôt
les plats que que j'affectionne plutôt
que de manger bêtement des souris et des
oiseaux comme font ses confrères et
consœurs il s'est arrondi avec les
années quand il est né il était il était
mince fit oui c'est vra on sent pas tous
même les yeux mis avec la bah écoutez
moi j'ai pas pris pris non mais vous
vous êtes parfait mais oui c'est le
risque évidemment avec l'âge mais alors
pourquoi le chat a grossit il a grossit
parce que je me il me faisait davantage
rire un peu plus rond
que oui et pardon aux personnes en
surpoids qui nous regardent mais c'est
vrai que une blague racontée par un gros
ou racontée par un anorexique c'est pas
na pas le même effet surtout quand c'est
une blague autour de l'alimentation et
la cuisine surtout quand le personnage
n'existe pas vraiment et donc je ne je
ne me moque de personnes il est
simplement lui-même il est comme ça on
me demanda aussi pourquoi il a un si
gros nez mais je dis imaginez-le avec un
petit nez il serait serait pas lui-même
et voilà c'est un peu le Cano de
Bergerac des animaux oui puis vous êtes
caricaturiste aussi he c'est un peu ça
votre votre votre trait voilà notre
métier consiste aussi à exagérer de
temps en temps le le trait euh on va
voir le chat parce que il parle beaucoup
d'alimentation alors on a ressorti
quelques quelques planches qu'on va
regarder ensemble où effectivement alors
là c'est quoi cinq fruits et légumes par
jour si on compte les fruits de mer
c'est supportable c'est les coquilles sa
ja vous parlez tout à mais oui voilà il
est pas très ou il est plutôt plein
sauce que que fruits et légumes le CH
voilà mais alors des comment il avait
fait un autre dessin de j'avais fait un
autre dessin tu vois comme je je dis
c'est politiquement increct ça vous avez
dû vous mettre les les di alors on dit
toujours que l'appétit vient en mangeant
mais force c'est de constater que
l'appétit part aussi en mangeant mais
oui on n'a jamais dit ça mais il part
surtout en mangeant évidemment c'est
vrai qu'à la fin d' repas on a moins
d'apppétit qu'au début donc quand vous
vous dites que les diététiciens auraient
pu me me reprocher ce dessin j'ai fait
un dessin sur eux un jour aussi les
diététiciens un bon diététicien doit
recevoir au moins CIN patients par jour
un avocat un cornichon et euh voilà je
sais plus ce que j'avais encore inventé
alors ça c'est encore un dessin al alors
voilà soit j'ai pris 1 kg soit ma
balance est passée à l'heure
d'été il sait il sait qu'il est gros
oui il vit bien avec bah oui voilà alors
vous avez aussi des engagements par
exemple sur le bien-être animal il peut
en en parler du chat sur il y a aussi
une planche où il est
végétarien alors ça c'est c'est quoi
c'est des messages que vous voulez faire
passer c'est selon le lecteur fait comme
il veut il je propose et il analyse et
il dispose je me sers évidemment des
grands thèmes d'actualité et non pas de
l'actualité au jour le jour c'est-à-dire
que je ne vais pas faire un commentaire
sur la déclaration du député machin
chouette à propos de de de la grève des
trucs machin non parce que dans 6 mois
et même dans 2 semaines on pensera à
autre chose on aura oublié donc mes
dessins n'auraient plus de sens dans si
vous relisez je vois qu'il y a l'album
ici qui est le premier c'est un album
c'est le premier paru en 86 et si on lit
des extraits de ce de cet album là on
rit encore et c'est ce que me disent des
enfants de 10 12 ans c'est toujours
d'actualité qui découvre les anciens
albums du chat et qui me dit mais ça
nous fait marrer c'est formidable et ça
n'aurait pas été le cas si j'avais fait
du dessin sur l'actualité politique du
jour alors on dit qu'en vieillissant et
que les chats en vieillissant ils
prennent un peu de poids vous l'avez dit
mais est-ce que on dit aussi qu'en
vieillissant devient rayac est-ce que
votre chat idéologiquement il a un peu
changé alors quand il était beaucoup
plus jeune et maintenant à 40 ans est-ce
qu'il est j'allais dire un peu plus à
droite al est-ce qu'il a jamais été à
gauche d'ailleurs si si vous regardez un
strip les strips c'est ces petites
bandes en trois cases donc il a un jour
fait la comparaison il a dit en en
politique souvent les gens commencent à
gauche puis il passe au centre et il
termine à droite comme moi dans ce strip
mais il n'y avait aucune allusion
politique non le chat est un humaniste
le chat je pense que j'essaie de l'être
moi aussi il prend tou il prend toujours
oui plutôt républicain même si c'est le
roi du gag mais euh il il prend toujours
la défense des plus faibles et et c'est
son honneur il y a j'ai fait des dessins
dans cet album là sur justement
l'imposition du port de la burka alors
justement on a ressorti ces ces quelques
dessins là on va les regarder ensemble
avec une bourka justement voilà tu
contestes le régime non j'ai lavé ma
bourka à 90°r au li de 60° voilà et ça
et ça vous fait rire et ça fait ça me
fait plaisir de voir votre grand sourire
en lisant ce ce dessin parce que que
j'aborde un sujet gravissime tragique
tragique et j'arrive à en faire rire le
chat est profondément laïque oui bien
sûr bien sûr et alors personne n'a
encore eu la véritable preuve de
l'existence de Dieu on attend toujours
le chat dit un jour sil est tellement
balaise que ça qu'il se fasse inviter un
jour au 20h et on sera fixé bon
mais moi j'ai créé le chat donc qu'un
être croit en son créateur c'est
possible puisque j'existe donc il croit
en Mo moi mais c'est déjà une forme de
croyance c'est déjà pas mal et puis le
chat est engagé aussi pour des causes
qui sont aussi plus plus sensible on
regarde ensemble qu'est-ce que tu
aimerais faire quand tu seras grand du
standup voilà et voilà et c'est le
dessin que j'ai oublié de mettre dans
l'album donc j'en ai un peu parlé en
présentant ce 24e
chat ce dessin là il est pas
stigmatisant qui est-ce qui est le plus
fort dans l'histoire c'est le gamin
parce qu'il a cette réplique je veux
faire du standup marchera jamais le
pauvre et beaucoup de personnes en
situation de handicap des gens en
fauteuil roulant viennent aux séances de
dédicace et me disent merci de nous
inclure dans vos gagues parce que ça
nous fait exister de façon plus normale
dans la société est-ce que le chat peut
rire de tout Oui jamais vous vous êtes
interdit un domaine une blague à cause
de ou parfois
non je le fais pas non non non j'ai oh
c'est comm comme tout le monde j'ai
parfois un dessin où je me dis non ça
c'est gratuit ça ser pas bien voilà euh
non il a même réussi à dire que si le
Prophète avait eu un frère jumeau lui le
frère on aurait pu le représenter sans
que ça pose de problème bon c'est une
manière d'aborder ce sujet hyper dans
débat des caricatures de Charlie voilà
c'est du d'une façon détournée donc
c'est aussi ça la force de de de
l'humour ou de la réflexion ou de de de
c'est de ne pas forcément prendre la
question frontalement puisqu'on sait
qu'elle peut générer de la tragédie mais
de la prendre euh par la bande et ça
permet de parler du sujet ça permet de
débattre ça permet de faire rire et
réfléchir et c'est tout le chat parce
qu'il a le sens de l'esquive aussi le
chat il est là il passe re
vous c'est contourner un obstacle au
dernier moment d'un coup de malgré son
nombre point il reste oui V il est
parfois il est parfois très fin jeu de
mot on va voir euh si vous êtes vraiment
incollable c'est le
quiz alors on a fait une exception pour
vous pour un quiz qui porte d'habitude
Philippe Gal sur la nourriture des
humains mais pour vous on l'a fait sur
la nourriture de nos animaux domestiques
chiens et chats sauriez-vous nous dire
si ces affirmations qui vont venir sont
vrais les premiers cakees industriels
pour animaux domestiques apparaissent en
1860 en Grande-Bretagne vrai oui c'est
vrai parfait au début du 20e siècle
apparaissent les premières pour animaux
à base de viande de cheval et de baleine
vrai ou
faux alors je dirais vrai oui vrai parce
qu'on estimait que c'était des viandes
pas nobles qui étaient pas très cheres
donc on les mettait et on les réservait
aux conserves de chats et chien pourquoi
pas c'était plutôt une bonne idée
ensuite je crois qu'il y a eu des tripes
qui sont arrivés aussi et qui ont fait
partie de ces conserves si la marque de
pâté pour chat indique AB base de poulet
il doit y en avoir au moins 30 % à
l'intérieur de la boîte vrai ou faux
faux il est trs je pense qu'il doit y en
avoir beaucoup moins mais comme souvent
dans TR 4 % sur la loi européenne ou 4 %
de poulet incollable
sur préparé nouriture pour dou le slogan
et ma boîte c'est du
poulet si vous préférez des recettes
maison pour votre chat voici trois
ingrédients à éviter absolument les
chocolats les lentilles vertes et le
blanc d'œuf vrai ou faux je dirais vrai
alors vrai pour le chocolat oui vrai
pour le blanc d'œuf mais faux pour les
lentilles c'est compliqué ça ah bah il y
avait un piège autrement tout juste av
piè cétait les lentilles c'est très bon
les lentilles pour les chat Ahès bien
oui voilà il apprend quel vous saurez
pour votre prochain chat le chat le le
chat dont nous parlons à un jour dit si
les lentilles vous font péter porte des
lunettes oui et ben il peut le dire
alors un deuxième quiz pour vous vous
avez publié vos premiers dessin dans la
revue l'œuf sariiez-vous nous dire si
ces affirmations sur l'œuf en cuisine
sont exact ah d'accord je croyais que
vous allez faire une comparaison avec ma
coiffure
mais je reconnais là votre délicatesse
si un œuf flotte à la surface de l'eau
dans un récipient ça signifie qu'il est
frais non ça signifie qu'il est pas
cette date parce que il y a une poche
d'air qui s'est agrandit dans la
coquille effectivement il est périmé B
un œuf mollet nécessite au moins 8
minutes dans l'eau bouillante 8 minutes
mollet non il va être dur à 8 minutes
mollet moi je dis V c'est voilà c'est 3
minutes pour le pour le pour le coque et
4 5 minutes pour le très très fort l'œuf
parfait est un œuf cuit à 65°gr pendant
45 minutes vrai ou faux vrai vrai c'est
exact oui c'est la cuisine à basse
température effectivement alors dernier
quiz pour faire un œuf à la coque il
doit être extra frais donc pondu depuis
au moins 4
jours alors j'ai eu des poules je parle
de l'animal
et j'ai mangé des œufs frais du jour
alors on dit que c'est pas recommandé
mais c'est tellement bon donc moi je
dirais l'œuf dès qu'il est pondu je peux
le non mais alors peut-être que c'est
mal formulé c'est quel est l'espacetemp
dans lequel il est toujours extra frais
est-ce que c'est 4 jours est-ce que
est-ce que après 4 jours on peut encore
le manger peut-être à la coque voilà à
mon avis c'est un peu plus long que ça
c'est 9 jours voilà bon alors
félicitations c'est rareon est même avec
des grands chef qu'on a un comme ça une
tot r quasiment sans faute à part ce
piège ignoble qui m'aattendu sur les
lentilles c'est vrai que c'était pas
très parce que si si on travaille en en
proportion j'ai tout de même répondu bon
à 2 tiers de de la question 2 tiers de
la question et en fournissant même les
réponses
parfois au degré prèsors on va voir si
vous êtes aussi fort sur le vin en tout
cas vous nous avez demandé ce Morgon on
est dans la région du beaujolet là
évidemment domaine la pierre qui est
bien connu là-bas c'est un vin rouge de
millésim 2022 le CPAGE c'est un c'est un
Gamet bien sûr et sa particularité en
général hein effectivement pour le
Morgon il y a quatre arômes dominant
cerise violette framboise et puis une
petite touche de régliss c'est ça qui
vous
plaît vous me la prenez parce que moi je
l'aime vous l'aimez à déguster je l'aime
pour ce qu'il l' est je le trouve juste
parfait c'est mon ami ciné le
dessinateur qui a fait les chats les
célèbres chats chariot Chapelin et
cetera qui m'a euh fait connaître le
Morgon la pierre c'est un ami à lui et
c'est un c'est une famille de
viticulteur qui a toujours privilégié la
biodynamie bien avant qu'on parle du du
vin bio et cetera donc je le trouve
parfait et j'en consomme avec modération
régul évidemment avec modération
toujours alors c'est souvent autour de
la table que se noue les meilleures
histoires que se fait parfois le deal en
politique alors c'est la brve de
comptoir on vous a demandé Philippe
gueluc de réfléchir à une anecdote
pourquoi pas en politique autour d'un
d'un repas est-ce que vous avez un
souvenir à nous raconter un souvenir
particulièrement marquant HM alors
marquan est très personnel les gens
demandent à l'avance pardon à la
personne si elle souhaite que je ne
révèle pas cela mais j'ai eu la chance
de rencontrer plusieurs fois François
Hollande euh chez des amis euh commun
qu'il le connaissait bien même chez un
couple de journalistes lorsqu'il était
Président nous avons dîné chez eux et
avec lui et c'est quelqu'un de très
sympathique très drôle très drôle en en
société et lors d'une de ses visites à
Bruxelles nous avons eu la chance qu'il
accepte une invitation à dîner à la
maison avec un grand médecin qui est le
bras droit du docteur mououeg vous savez
qui est l'homme qui répare les femmes au
sud qui vous donc c'était pour servir
très belle cause voilà et ce soir-là
j'avais préparé je pense mes petites
coquilles saint-jac dont je vous avais
parlé et cetera il s'était régalé Julie
Gaillet était là et au moment des
fromages je lui a apporté une planche
sur laquelle j'avais mis un camambert
président
et un morceau de Hollande
demi-vieux ça lui a plu une attention
particulière ça l'a fait rire parce
qu'il a dit pourquoi du demi-vieux dit
mais jeis tout de même pas vous servir
du Holland jeune ce n'est plus
d'actualité alors on va continuer parce
que vous nous avez demandé une
blanquette mais ni frites ni bière ni
chocolat qui sont trois grandes
spécialités belges alors nous et bien on
a décidé quand même et bien de faire
plaisir à nos téléspectateurs et de
parler de la frite et de ses secrets de
fabrication et c'est le dessous des
plats dans le Nord on ne plaisante pas
avec la frite mais est-ce là-bas qu'
sont les meilleurs alors pour trancher
une bonne fois pour toutes la ville
d'aras a décidé d'organiser il y a
quelques jours le premier Championnat du
Monde du genre ma Frémont et nos
confrères de France Télévision ont joué
les juges
arbitres plus qu'une spécialité
culinaire presque un objet de culte la
frite c'est la vie quand même hein au
pays de la pomme de terre une bonne
frite fait Tach d'huile autant chez les
amateurs que chez les professionnels la
frite c'est la convivialité la sympathie
la fraîcheur et c'est la fête surtout
c'est un produit régional et quiéchauffe
le cœur et les papill dans le Nord on ne
blague pas avec la
frite on a tout ouais je même pas
vérifier couteau et tout avant d'entrer
en scène Thomas
stress pour nous c'est une première
alors n donne le temps et tout on est on
est sous pression le concours est lancé
top chrono une heure pour éplucher
tailler et frire les pommes de terre
l'objectif est clair casser la baraque
en faisant la meilleure frite du monde
Thomas mise tout sur un ingrédient
secret ESS de faire un peu la DIF avec
le sel le fameux sel à l'Ille noir on
verra mais voilà pour ce tout premier
championnat du monde de la frite la
concurrence est rude face à leur
friteuse 32 candidats s'affrontent
chacun choisit sa variété de pommes de
terre et son huile dans la catégorie
frit familial les frère Benjamin et
Johann veulent se démarquer nous on part
sur une variété déjà qui est pas une
variété de destinée à la frite par sur
une grande Charlotte et on l'a fait en
trois cuissons donc 130 140 170 180 et
un dernier bain à 190 des candidats
français belges mais aussi canadiens ou
encore japonais avec cette recette de
frites soufflé l'art de la frite une
maîtrise loin d'être facile qu'en disent
les membres du jure visuellement elles
sont très appétissantes elles sont bien
dorées voilà elles sont bien
assaisonnées le croustingent à
l'extérieur et la texture à l'intérieur
ça va jouer dans la nuance parce que là
on a que des candidats de très haute
qualité dans une ambiance populaire le
public aussi s'en régale très très bonne
croustillante bon goût de pomme de terre
comme on les aime
génial et le premier champion du monde
de la frite est français une belle
conclusion pour une journée
fatigante et quelques semaines de
préparation et surtout ça ça récompense
le travail que je fais tous les jours à
la fritterie un lilois l'emporte avec
une recette de tubercule cuite à l'huile
puis au gras de bœuf quoi de plus
naturel dans cette région qui garde la
patate depuis des siècles Philippe guuc
c'est un français qui a qui est champion
du monde de la frite c'est un affront
pour un belge non parce qu'il a
certainement fait un stage chez nous
pour apprendre ce beau métier j'ai j'ai
vu observer trois choses qui me me
plaise c'est qu'on a parlé d'huile et de
blanc de bœuf gr de buf gras de bœuf on
appelle ça blanc de buf voilà un peu un
peu des deux parce que voilà que on a
parlé de plusieurs bains parce que
l'erreur c'est de cuire les frites une
fois alors deux ou trois mais le dernier
un petit peu plus Chud c'est important
pour les et que j'ai vu que des
personnes dégustaient une barquette avec
de la mayonnaise en Belgique on mange
des frites avec de la mayonnaise avec
toujours sinon c'est ah ben sinon c'est
c'est pêché c'est pêché donc et on
narrive pas à convaincre nos amis qu'
faut au moins essayer c'est la
mayonnaise ou c'est une sauce parce que
j'ai entendu dire c'était une sauce mais
pas forcément la
mayonnaise vous avez la tartare vous
avez mayonnaise vous avez la sauce
andalouse vous avez truc évidemment mais
avec la mayonnaise alors je vous
recommande un jour de venir au mois de
novembre s'il fait froid et qu'il pleu
vine vous venez à Bruxelles vous prenez
un cornet de frites vous vous mettez
sous un abri de bus et vous dégustez un
paquet de frites brûlantes à la
mayonnaise en attendant le TR vous vous
allez les acheter forcément à la
friterie ou vous en faites à la maison
non à la friterie oui pas fr pas de
frite chez vous non trop galère ça sent
mauvais ça sent la frite voilà ça
représente quoi la la la frite pour vous
on entendait là c'est la vie c'est la
fête ou c'est magnifique c'est un truc
qu'on se fait régulièrement avec des
copains on va se faire un cinéma en fin
d'après-midi et on termine à la
friterie debout avec vot cornd debout
avec votre cornet de frites oui bien sûr
et on va se boire une bière une bière
belge avec avec un cornet de frites
c'est un repas complet ça pour vous ah
oui oui après après on va pas par je
dire on dit la frite c'est la vie mais
si les cardiologues nous écoutent ils
disent plutôt la frite c'est le gras
quand même he bien sûr mais enfin il
faut avec modération je veux dire chaque
fois qu'on boit un coup on doit dire
avec modération chaque fois qu' je c'est
pareil et alors vous vous en mangé très
régulièrement encore aujourd'hui non non
non je mange des frites une fois oui
c'est ça c'est exceptionnel une fois par
10 jours ou par de semaines sû oui oui
oui j ah nous c'est tous les 6 mois donc
ça va et on peut mettre n'importe quelle
variété parce qu'on a vu là certains ont
tenté des choses avec des en principe
des pommes de terre qui ne sont pas
utilisé pour pour la frite pour vous
c'est c'est en principe c'est la Binch
pour vous c'est seulement la Binch ouais
j'ai pas j'ai pas poussé les analyses
plus plus avant oui parce qu'il y a un
débat sur les chaires fermes et chair un
peu moins fermes qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire PL c'est plutôt farineuse c'est
plutôt farineuse oui oui parce que la
chairferme ça peut enfin voilà ou elle
peut être très longue à cuire surtout la
chair ferme alors que pour vous elle
ressemble à quoi une bonne frite c'est
une frite large ou plutôt allumette
qu'est-ce qu'elle doit avoir
c'est le c'est c'est cette taille là
c'est que les pommes àumettes c'est
mignon ce truc mais c'est voilà alors
autant manger des chips euh les frites
trop grosses c'est épouvantable parce
que là autant faire des croquettes de de
dans la ch l'impression de manger de la
purée à voà non il y a un Gabaret alors
j'ai j'ai pas mesuré avant de venir je
me mais mais je vous garantis que vous
venez à la frit chez nous on dit la
friture et pas la friterie vous venez
ouai oui vous venez à la friture Antoine
place Jourdin à Bruxelles c'était le
quartier de mon enfance et je retourne
encore là où je vois les arrières petits
enfants du créateur c'est une tradition
c'est culturel en fait un peu oui et
puis c'est bon tout simplement elle doit
être bien croustillante à l'extérieur
c'estoui voilà
ouais elle doit être vraiment dorée vous
pouvez demander bien cuite truc il y a
rien de pire qu'une frite molle
excusez-moi oui on aien tout à l'heure
vous disiez que votre meilleure
blanquette était à Paris mais j'imagine
que c'est pas à Paris qu'on trouve la
meilleure frite dès qu'on s'éloigne de
la Belgique le Nord ça va en champion du
monde Jeanpierre oui mais le Champion du
Monde il est de lîle hein il est Nord
est-ce que dès qu'on s'éloigne du Nord
de la France même si on est en France
quand on arrive vers la capitale ou dans
le sud on arrive à manger des bonnes
frites est-ce que la frite a conquis
toute la France maintenant on fait des
bonnes frites partout on mange plus de
frites en France qu'en Belgique ça c'est
des des des chiffres que j'ai découvert
un jour et amusé mais il y a des je
trouve qu'il y a des des nourritures des
boissons qui sont liées à à un pays ou à
une région buvez un pastisse sur le port
de Marseille parfait vous buvez le même
pastisse devant la garde de duseldorf il
n'aura pas la même saveur pas le même
goût est-ce que àaveugle vous seriez
reconnaître une une frite maison d'une
frite surgelée parce que il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de frites surgelé bien sûr
c'est vrai oui oui bien sûr le le ça me
fait rebondir mais j'aime bien citer le
chat de truc parce qu'il dit dans une
dégustation à l'aveugle le plus dur
c'est de trouver le tirebouchonou et
donc des des frites à l'aveugle ça peut
être compliqué mais si on met d'aller
manger bien sûr jamais de frit surgelée
ouais mais une bonne frite surgelée peut
être meilleure qu'une mauvaise frite pas
surgelée je je viens ou mais si on va si
si on va par là bien sûr un un excellent
verre d'eau peut être bien meilleur
qu'un vin de merde je monre pas celulà
évid alors on voit apparaître
aujourd'hui parce que des frites de
patates douces des frites de tarot
est-ce que vous admettez cette
concurrence ù vous trouvez que non sur
la frite il y a pas de débat c'est la
patate ah non non non le frire est le
propre de l'homme h euh
donc faisons frire tout ce qu'on peut
faire frire moi je dis plus on frit et
plus on peut l'appeler
frit avoir la dénomination frit quand
même l'appeler frite ah non on appelle
ça patate douce frites ou ou ou ou
beignet de carottes ou de ma frite pour
pour vous non non la frite madame c'est
la pomme de terre alors aujourd'hui on
trouve aussi beaucoup de frites à cuire
au four par exemple est-ce que vous vous
trouvez que c'est une anomalie ça non je
l'ai tenté je l'ai essayé mais j'en suis
revenu c'est pas terrible d'abord il y a
une dépense d'énergie considérable pour
faire chauffer un four à 200°r pour
cuire une assiette de frites c'est un
petit peu aberrant donc c'est moins bon
j'éviterai mais oui oui oui restons au
il y a des trucs qui on vous aimez les
traditions vous en fait j'aime les
traditions alors j'aime revisiter les
choses mais si la visite n'est pas
conuante j'abandonne je reviens à la
tradition voilà faire bien effectuer tu
es bien un plat traditionnel ou préparer
admirablement un ma je un neœuf au plat
ça peut être raté ça peut être réussi si
le jaune devient un peu dur à la fin
c'est pas bien donc ça doit être parfait
et le faux plat oui on le prépare depuis
des siècles sans doute mais je tire mon
chapeau
toujours à la personne qui me fait un
très belle faux plat est-ce que le chat
il va à la friture de temps en temps
j'ai en feuillet temp je n'ai pas à
trouver de frites avec le ch mais
j'imine sans doute non j'ai dû faire des
dessins oui oui sur Bruxelles mais vous
savez euh les les les euh je crois que
j'ai fait un jour un dessin il est à
tablé avec il un paquet de frites et une
bière et il dit tout le monde s'étonne
de voir un chat manger des frites
personne ne se pose la question qu'il
est en train de boire une bière bon
parce que voilà mais c'est plutôt
anecdotique c'est pas le message que je
veux porter à travers la planète c'est
de dire attention je suis originaire de
là et je veux que ça sache h
alors on va parler maintenant de la
cuisine italienne puisque vous nous
faites voyager vous avez dit que c'était
une de vos cuisines aussi préférées mais
est-elle meilleure que notre gastronomie
française on en parle et on met les
pieds dans le
plat alors Brigit Sion Chauvin la
meilleure gastronomie au monde est sans
doute la française soyons honnête la
cuisine plébicité de Tokyo à San
Francisco en passant par chez nous et
par la Belgique c'est l'italienne la
preuve avec ce reportage d'éè Bonduel et
de Philippe
[Musique]
LEC de la burata avec de la crème de
poisiche c'est super bon gûu c'est joli
c'est coloré on se régale c'est la
cuisine la plus populaire au monde celle
de la botte 94% des Français déclarent
que la cuisine italienne est leur
cuisine préférée une passion de longue
date mais ravivé ces derniers temps par
l'ouverture de restaurants ou de concept
store comme ici en plein cœur de Paris
2500 m car entièrement dédié à l'Italie
évidemment tout vient d'Italie donc
toutes les régions sont représenté
différents types de lait les lait de
chèv les lait de blche les lait de
buffelon pareil sur les charcuteries
vous avez les spécialités iconiques la
mortadella les jambons de Parme et saint
Daniel et puis après des choses un peu
plus précises comme la bressa voilà de
différentes de différentses types 5000
références de produits italiens 5
restaurants et la plus grande cave de
vins italiens aussi avec plus de 14000
bouteilles 1500 références on a des vins
de toutes les régions du nord au sud de
l'Italie des vins des îles de la Sicile
mais alors d'où vient cette passion
française pour cette
gastronomie sans surprise c'est une
cliente italienne qui nous en parle le
mieux elle est joyeuse en fait et ben
Var je pense que c'est ça elle est très
gourmande elle est riche en fait mais
aussi simple mais il y a pas besoin
d'ingrédients particulièrement riches
pour faire des recettes qui soient
bonnes et sympa à partager en parlant de
recette Philippe geluc nous avions une
spécialité à vous proposer Philippe
geluc je pense qu'il serait peut-être
intéressé par un gin de chalet qui
pourrait préparer pour faire la pasta la
carbonara donc c'est une pâte voilà
metero par exemple qui qui vient bien
absorber cette sauce qui est faite à
base d'œuf avec le gin de chalet qui est
un produit particulier assez salé un peu
croquant parce qu'on le fait griller et
donc ça donne un plat qui est gourmand
et généreux et je pense que ça ça lui
plairait les pâtes justement savez-vous
que plus de 14 milliards d'assiettes de
pâtes sont consommé chaque année à
travers le
monde alors Monsieur quiz j'ose même pas
demander ce que c'est que le guanchalet
vous savez ex guchalet c'est de la jou
de sangli exactement ah de sangli ou de
por oui le vrai c'est de sangler parce
que la recette est née carbonara c'était
les types qui cherchent qui du charbon
de bois dans les mon mais après
aujourd'ui c'est Plô préféré comme le
dis ce monsieur là c'est ça pourrait
vous plaire ah oui j'adore j'adore ça le
gancha mais vous faites la vraie
carbonara sans la crème juste avec l'œuf
qui ouais c'est ça fa ça comme je vous
disais le CO et PP avec juste du poivre
de l'eau c'est porino et poivre c'est ça
Co et P et mais ça m'étonne de vous vous
ayez découvert le CATU et ppé il y a pas
très longtemps c'est non je le
connaissais depuis longtemps mais je me
suis risqué à faire oui parce c'est très
compqué absolument oui du premier coup
du premier coup non c'est hyper facile
mais alors je passe toutes mes vacances
en Italie et dans un coin perdu de
lomberie et quand on dit qu'il faut
regarder la provenance des produits je
vous jure que c'est vrai dans la petite
dans la grande surface du de du de la
petite ville à côté de chez nous je
trouve des tomates de Hollande oui en
plein été rendu au milieu de l'Italie et
je me dis mais qui sont ces crétins qui
font rouler des camions pour transporter
des tomates de Hollande alors qu' dans
le pays de la tomate et de d'emmener de
l'eau gazeuse dans le Nord enfin voilà
il y a une aberération de ce côté-là et
je trouve qu'on devrait légiférer à ce
propos alors vous êtes plus pasta ou
pizza nous écout ah la la la pasta parce
que la pizza je trouve que c'est j'ai
fait je prépare selon la recette d'une
vieille cuisinière du sud de l'Italie la
pizza frita qui est très peu connu alors
tu fais une une non non une une pâte à
pizza et au lieu de la CU de la garnir
et de la cuire au four tu prépares la
garniture donc une sauce tout simplement
tomate avec quelques feuilles de basilic
et là et tu mets la dans l'huile dans
dans dans un tout petit peu d'huile dans
une poêle en fonte et tu fais frire la
pâte et tu la puis tu mets le ah ouais
ça être bon ça c'est sub c'est une
recette dou de quelle région je pas
d'une d'une vieille dame qui sauf
qu'elle est frite ou un petit peu non
non et puis le dessus n'est pas frit
n'est pas n'est pas fondu et cetera
c'est très très bon donc plutôt pâte
que que pizza bien sûr parce que la pâte
c'est infini les les recettes de
préparation sont infin la plus simple et
et la meilleure chaque italien chaque
italien rêve des pâtes de sa maman c'est
des pâtes sauce tomate vous êtes un
dingue sur le aldenteé vous êtes très
vigilant un accro alors non moi j'aime
pas quand c'est trop trop dur mais il
faut pas non plus que ce soit tout tout
à fait mou mais vous inventez des
recettes autour des pâtes oui mais je me
souviens plus de ce que j'ai inventer
euh donc si vous me demandez le truc je
sais pas oui bien sûr je tente je tente
des choses on peut mettre beaucoup de
choses a on finit le frigo et on fait
une sauce et on la met dans les pâtes ça
marche à peu près toujours hein
évidemment oui enfin faut vérifier aussi
ce qu'on a dans le dans le frigo parce
qu'un jour type qui s'est laissé prendre
il y avait des vieux médicaments qui
devaient conserver au frais et toute sa
famille non non vous en faites souvent
vous vous en préparez régulièrement à la
maison les pâtes oui oui alors le le le
plus le plus simple c'est le bolo le
fameux bolo que eux appellent al ragou
parce que voilà VI bise
c'est de la viande hachée frites avec
des oignons et puis tomat et je fais
toujours le oui si on veut la faire un
peu mieux il peut y avoir un peu de vin
un peu de célerie un peu de tomate un
peu de carottes un peu d'oignon si on
veut le faire le ragou non et bien non
monsieur pas la vra alors c'est pas pour
moi c'est un peu de l'ARD de queonata
pour ah peut-être pour moi c'est pas
qu'on le fait mieux c'est qu'on le fait
autrement mais pour moi surtout en
cuisine italienne c'est le truc bas
oignons tomate huile d'olive et on fait
la meilleure sauce tomate du monde pas
besoin de rajouter forcément de l'origan
ou de l'ail ou des trucs comme ça après
on peut aussi je ne déteste pas mais je
j'aime bien le le basique pourquoi on
est tous fous de la cuisine italienne à
votre avis question parce que
contrairement à ce que à l'idée un petit
peu reçu elle est très varié parce que
leurs produits sont excellents et parce
que
euh et parce que c'est bon tout
simplement bon c'est vous me demandez de
parler de tout ça devant un Paris Bress
a je crois que Philippe guuc a raison
c'est la culture du produit en Italie
moi je connais l'ombri aussi moi je suis
toujours frappé en Italie vous allez
dans la moindre petite épicerie et bien
il y a du fromage à la découpe de la
char cré à la découpe c'est incroyable
il y a une fulltitude de de
d'appellations de variétés d'espèces
qu'on a pas en France où on est très
vite sur des produits qui sont déjà CT
la moindre tratoria est excellente toute
petitte tratoria on mange excessivement
je suis sûr vous préférez dans une
tratoriaque dans un étoilé ah oui voilà
euh non non c'est bien mais sur la
terrasse de la tratoria s'il fait beau
j'ai le ciel étoilet audessus de moi les
deux vous avez les deux vous vous
connaissez bien les différentes pattes
parce que il y a les spaghettis il y a a
un certain nombre de les
orquettés la maaroni
les les P les mini P les les orquettes
tout Oui Oui
Jez vous AZ l'impression que c'est pas
le même plat finalement quand on change
de de mais certaines pâtes et d'ailleurs
c'est ce que défendent les les
spécialistes de la cuisine italienne
certaines pâtes accrochent mieux tel ou
tel genre de sauce et donc c'est
cylindrique la sauce vient se nicher
dedans c'estux voà et voilà bien sûr
toujours aussi toujours mélanger la
sauce dans la casserole retirer du feu
plutôt que de servir des assiettes sur
lesquelles on met la sauce et vous
remettez les pâtes dans la dans la sauce
avant de les de les servir oui mais il
est italien ou belge Philippe gu vous
connaissez la cucina poovera si quand mê
ouais vous êtes mais il y a les frites
aux patates les les pâtes aux patates
par ex les pâtes aux pates j'ai jamais
pris ah bah ça c'est le pâ aux patates
ça c'est léger ça ça c'est très lég non
parce que mais non c'est c'est un faux
vous mangez deux fois moins de pâtes et
deux fois moins de Pat qu'un plat de
pâte ou qu'un plat de patate mélanger
avec un peu de panchetta et du romarin
c'est extraordinaire un tout petit peu
calorique mais rien pour le chat c'est
parfait d'accord et les pâtes aux frites
non vous ne me les recomm P au poich
kcina povera encore d'accord très bien
ils ont aussi l'Arte Povera en Italie
mais quelle richesse alors vous savez
qu' en France on a beaucoup de fromage
le général de Gaul disait comment
gouverner un pays au 258 variétés de de
fromage il y en a aussi beaucoup en
Italie j'ai regardé 54 appellations
est-ce que vous vous êtes fan aussi de
ces fromages italiens on raffole de la
mozzarella ouou de la burata en France
alors mozzarella debouffala seulement
parce que la mozzarella de vache
m'intéresse pas le pcorino c'est juste
magnifique et on avait un voisin qui en
faisait lui-même donc je vous raconte
pas le parmesan n'en parlons pas
toujours le regiano parce que le grand
padan ah ben c'est pas du parmeson le
Grandin panado he bah il se fait passer
pour hein ah oui mais on est d'accord
vous l'avez débusqué oui oui alors le le
B tout c'est formidable comment comment
on appelle le fromage avec du verre là
le qui est coulant le mascarpone
gorgonzola ggonzol la
fontina alors ce qu'il faut faire aussi
quand on fait ses courses là-bas c'est
être à côté d'une dame qui fait ses
courses une italienne et prendre ce
qu'elle a commandé aussi j'ai découvert
un saucisson salam
Toscano parce qu'elle
dit salam Toscano alors je dis c sa
cause il y a le vilani aussi qui est
très bon absol ou si vous êtes dans une
ville que vous ne connaissez pas et que
vous voulez découvrir un bon petit
restaurant qui n'est pas fréquenté par
les touristes vous vous mettez à une
terrasse de bistro à côté de trois vieux
pépères qui prennent l'apéro des
Italiens et puis quand il se lèvent vous
les suivez et eux connaissent rest voilà
vous allez chez l'habitant sinon
peut-être mais vous préférez fromage
français italien j'ai l'impression que
votre choix est fait il y a pas de match
Italie non non non je suis très fromage
français aussi bien sûr non non moi je
trouve que nous sommes complémentaire et
je vous parlerai dans une autre émission
des fromages belges dont il y a une
infinité de de
variétés on connait moins les fromages
bel d'ailleurs le roi Boin a dit un jour
régner sur un pays au 263 fromages c'est
Moza ou burata parce qu'il y a il y a un
débat il y a un duel entre les deux
mozzarella ou burata non je trouve la
burata trop il y a pas de la burata de
bufflon non non non donc si il y avait
peut-être ça pourrait m'intéresser mais
ce que non plutôt la la mozerella de
bufflot et alors la TR la burata en fait
euh n'est pas très tellement dégusté en
Italie elle est surtout à l'exportation
et nous on en rafole mais eux pas
tellement exactement pour la petite
histoire la mozzarella de Buffalon c'est
un un fromage qui a plusieurs siècles et
qui était considéré comme un fromage
très prestigieux au 16e siècle c'était
côté à la Bourse et pour riposter à ce
fromage d'un point de vue marketing les
Pouilles ils ont inventé il y a pas très
longtemps cette Bata mais effectivement
elle est vous avez raison elle est elle
plaît davantage au bobo parisiens qu'aux
italiens qui préfèrent la vraie mozza
c'est un fromage un peu marqueté la
burata ah enrichi à la crème fraîche et
voilà c'est c'est une enveloppe de
mozzarella avec de la crème à
l'intérieur c'est comme tous les
produits qu'on nous vend genre chips et
Machin Truc croquant il y a du gras du
sucre et du sel et ça ça attire est-ce
que le chat voyage est-ce qu'il est déjà
allé en Italie il est traduit en italien
mais lui-même ah il est traduit en
italien oui oui il il gâte et lu et
lui-même non ouais il voyage avec moi
quand je le dessine là-bas mais sinon
non il n'a pas fait de de pris ses
valises pour aller en Italie non allez
je vois que vous lorniez sur ce Paris
Brest on va passer au dessert et c'est
votre péché
mignon comme diraent les journalistes il
le gâteau la transition est toute faite
avec le par
Brest qui est un un must de la
pâtisserie française alors vous savez
que ce fromage rappelle la roue d'un
cycliste parce que c'est un oui et je
vous rappelle que vous venez de dire ce
fromage non ah ce fromage ce dessert
rappelle la roue d'un d'un vélo parce
que il avait été fait par un pâtissier
de maison Lafite en hommage à cette
course qui s'appelle Paris Brest mais
j'ai aussi découvert qu'il y avait une
course qui s'appelait Paris Bruxelles
est-ce que il y a un gâteau et un
dessert qui est qui é fait comme ça avec
une roue en hommage à Paris-Bruxelles
vous ne croyez pas si bien dire et je
l'ai découvert il y a pas très longtemps
c'est un grand cuisinier euh bruxellois
dont le nom m'échappe et je lui en
demande pardon mais je le cite toujours
vous voyez ce que c'est la gaufre de
Bruxelles c'est une grande gaufre très
légère saoudré de de sucre glace et bien
il a coupé cette gaufre en deux dans le
sens de la longueur et il y a mis le le
le le pralinet qu'on met dans le Paris
Brest et il a appelé ça le Paris
Bruxelles ah benah voilà je trouve ça
trop Jol donc vous vous en trouvez
finalement non il a fait ça pour lors
d'une soirée spéciale de relation
Paris-Bruxelles mais je voudrais qu'il
lance ça dans le commerce que ce soit
officiel mais c'est pas tout à fait la
même pâte puisque là c'est une pâte à
chou c'est assez différent de la il est
il est très très beau alors il très beau
c'est aussi chez Françoise évidemment
qu' a cuisiné pour nous aujourd'hui
j'imagine que vous avez vos adresses
aussi à Paris pour trouver les les très
bons Paris Brest non alors je vais faire
parce que en télé on allait c'est odieux
quand on
voit pas très
facile il y a des paris brestes carré
maintenant ça vous choque ou vous
trouvez que c'est une hérésie ou peu
importe si a ch trouve aussi en forme
d'éclair on en trouve de tout maintenant
non je veux dire qu'on s'amuse avec la
forme c'est même pas non non c'est non
non oh il est très très bon bravo
Françoise merci trèson vous en trouvez
aussi à Bruxelles de du de le vraiest
avec la pâte à chou là non chez nous on
mange des frites madame mais voilà c'est
ça puis vous n'avez pas envie de manger
là-bas c'est comme le pastisce à du S
d'orf à du S d'orf voilà manger en Paris
Brest à Hong Kong ça n'a pas le même
même truc surtout qu'avec des baguettes
c'est pas facile à manger est-ce que
vous avez d'autres desserts que vous
nous enviez depuis depuis la Belgique
h on n'est pas mauvais dans les desserts
on a est-ce qu'il y a des choses alors
par exemple chez nous l'éclair au
chocolat il est fourré de crème
pâtissière et non pas de crème brune au
chocolat ah oui voilà avec c'est pas un
éclair au chocolat en fait si parce que
il y a un un napage glçage de de
chocolat d'accord et poette
poouette on est quand même les champions
la pâtisserie non vous nêtes pas
d'accord mais vous êtes les meilleurs
alors attendez on va conclure cette vous
êtes parfait dans tous les domaines vous
avez éclairé le monde de votre
intelligence et de votre savoire à
partir de 18 à une époque voilà
maintenant il y a deux trois ampoules
qui sont grillées mais vous continuez
tout de même vous avez la meilleure
Gastr déb du monde non oui oui c'est
vrai la Gast vous avez sans doute les
meilleurs pâtissiers vous avez les
meilleurs vins du monde vous avez le le
le personnel Pol non je vais pas aller
sur ce j'ai peur de la chute non je t'ai
plus et vous avez les meilleurs lecteurs
du chat du monde puisque le le chat est
tellement heureux d'être d'être lu dans
ce pays mais oui oui c'est un grand
bonheur pour fréquentez les bar au chat
parce que moi j'ai vu que ça existait
main barchat non non non alors vous
seriez vous devriez faire des
conférences dans les barchats ou vous
croyez honnêtement que j'ai que ça à
merci Philippe GUC d'avoir été
avec nous aujourd'hui d'avoir partagé ce
repas merci à che Françoise qui nous a
fourni ces bons plats comme comme
d'habitude merci Jean-Pierre merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve bien sûr la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de politique à
table sur LCP